this dress was just blowing in the gosh
i know mother nature just blessing me
today
[Music]
tell me who you're wearing and tell me
about the looks for tonight how many
changes will there be i am wearing
custom vera wing
one of my favorites and there is
there's a lot of changes a lot of
changes
how are you feeling what's your energy
like right now i'm feeling great i think
i got sushi in my trailer that i'm
trying to like get back to and
nibble on um but it's really exciting
it's so much fun i love doing anything
live so here we are well you're you're
used to it you're so good at it but can
you tell me any behind the scenes
secrets about what you will experience
over the next few hours do we have like
a super quick backstage change or is
there anything you got to do there's
there's multiple there's multiple we're
doing looks
and a few of them
you've had a busy weekend i saw you made
time to go to miss sarah highlands
bridal shower
who said get a friend for life like
vanessa hudson's what was that day like
and what was it like to finally see her
celebrate it oh my gosh
insane i am like still emotional over it
i've just i've known her for so long and
we've been waiting for this wedding for
so long and then come if it happened and
couldn't do it um but it's just so
exciting she looks so beautiful
i melt i just melt okay i'll let you go
but just in a couple words what will we
get tonight excitement entertainment
and thrills
[Music]